before you go into an Asian supermarket
I'm gonna give you guys a heads up if
you are a person of the kakizou nature
meaning you're white don't be scared
just walk inside touch things ask
questions most likely they're not going
to speak English but that's okay don't
be scared to try things that you're that
you don't know what it is
[Music]
little pig feet a little bull balls a
little duck ankle some pig nose as a pig
you
don't be scared
and look at that off in the distance we
have our friend Lin she's here shopping
maybe she can help us as you can see I'm
acting as if I didn't know she was
already here lid yeah she she actually
came with me I was just pretending like
she wasn't here but we're actually going
to be cooking some pretty nice food
today and the Lim is gonna help us
figure out how to make that [ __ ] because
I don't know how to make jungle food but
ban hub xeo how do you pronounce this
for our people out there this specific
thing is called bulk when sale but what
we're making is called button [ __ ] urban
gang depending on what region you're
from so if you guys haven't met this is
my right-hand woman Vanessa she's the
most [ __ ] disgusting creature I've
ever met in my life
won't you go ahead and explain to people
what I didn't know about the female body
when it comes to having your period
subtitles were used in this next clip
because you wouldn't know what the [ __ ]
she said if I didn't okay so what
happened this morning was I was plated
David what happens in your periods that
your uterus or is it what is a uterus
swells up so pushes are your bowels you
just poop a lot right she has a [ __ ]
boyfriend can you believe that power
back [ __ ] hi my name it my name is
David I'm going to be cooking you
something two days
we're going to be cooking from the
Vietnam meaning from the heart meaning
it's going to be fresh but dirty elsita
Jack bang thought I left a melon Charcot
bang boom boom bang bang bang boom boom
bang bang boom chicka pow pow yeah
that's enough
[Music]
anyways welcome back so as you see we
have our lovely guests here once again
because we're cooking two things and
she's gonna be making one of my favorite
favorite things on earth yep
I actually had this for the first time
when she made it and I don't know how to
make it at home I don't even know what
it's called to order it at a restaurant
so she's gonna do it for us today what
are we cooking Lynn Lynn we're making
fun court but again depending on what
region of Vietnam your family's from you
could call it medical or burn care you
might know it's cousin the bigger
version of it known as fun sale anyways
it's the mini version of it pretty much
that's the best way I can explain it
it's rice cakes there's a little bit of
tapioca in there a little bit of
turmeric a lot of people mistake in it
as eggs mixed into the batter but it's
actually too much that makes it yellow
and tasty and beautiful we're gonna use
these cast iron pots we're gonna make
the topping for the fun talk button guy
turn on your flame on your side baby so
this is going to be David's making the
topping that goes on top of the bun
again or bun color and it's just green
onions mixed with Chinese salad is that
what you called it yesterday I just call
this oh is this the Chinese chives yes
the garlic chives
the garlic chives it's just a mixture of
both let me see what you put the corn
this one's actually Oh because last time
when I was put in oil into the pot you
made a comment did I put too much oil in
it and that was unhealthy so I made an
adjustment throw that in there swirl it
up with the chopsticks I like two cups
of chopped garlic chives a lot of people
don't do this but I think it adds a
little bit to it a little bit of sugar
in there secret ingredient fish sauce
and everything throw that in there too
it's a little bit cool spot about a
teaspoon and a half that's it yep oh no
no the pan still hot so it'll still heat
it through oh so we don't actually want
to cook it like til it's wilted down No
we just want to cook it off real quick
warm it up yeah rice in this boiling
water so we're done with this yes that's
all done oh let's put this off to the
side yeah I just start throwing stuff in
I just don't share in there okay
that's about it's like a cup and a half
of two cups of water
well six or seven tablespoons of sugar
yeah which one is it this one
there you go that's it so you just turn
on the Cape just to dilute just to
dissolve the sugar and now we just have
to let that cool put that to the side so
this is the batter that we're gonna use
to make one [ __ ] what's in it David
what's inside this bond [ __ ] it's going
to be tumeric beads which is how you get
that yellow color I'm talking about rice
flour we're talking about water and
we're all talking about coconut milk
yeah we made it ahead of time and we
didn't do it on camera because it needs
some time to you know to mingle you love
each other that's right who hit on each
other first and unites relationship
Vince really gonna pay oh okay remember
cast-iron pans are hot there's no heat
resistant [ __ ] on the handles or
anywhere else or these pots so make sure
you use one of these bad boys silicone
gloves towels whatever you have at home
so we're gonna put oil down usually well
we'll just do it okay and we're gonna
take a shrimp and throw it in there not
yet
oh I'll give you this one so it's easier
don't burn yourself Oh mister oh good
yeah also we're spreading it around yeah
with your friends because when you do
get to learn different cuisines madman's
if your friend is not the same I can't
believe you're gonna cut these shrimps
in half I did that last time we made it
for you I know but that's why I thought
you were stingy and cheaper I'm sorry
just kidding
one entire ladle will fit about two of
them so you don't have to do it
so whoo did you hear that
that was a crackle in a season like that
Shh I say good job in venom easy ghin
joy joy mm-hmm
I'm waving like you're a wet tongue
David I know what that what what you say
you talkin [ __ ] you talkin [ __ ] I know
you are I'm not all right is that right
that is right now put your lid on yo
this is cooking and the cast-iron
dimpled pots we were gonna finish up on
that fish sauce after we let the sugar
in the water cool how cool is it David
it's cool enough where I can put my
finger in it and nothing happens whoa
watch this when you put things in to let
it cascade let it be beautiful for
camera oh wow so you're gonna squeeze
lemon our line whatever you have we have
lime ah always lime just do one person
then taste it
have a good forearm get your fingers
like this and squeeze that [ __ ] in
there like so if you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you can't do this oh this
kind of hurts I got these two hands
we're just gonna put the so this isn't
and everything my mom does it so I'm
doing it just like mash mash mash mash
oh wow and then I have some minced what
is that garlic yeah yeah you are slow we
are trying to do a cooking show woman
let's go this is gonna burn by the time
you're done okay I have minced garlic
and pepper in there throw it in there
wow wow wow wow
stir it up stir it up stir it up stir it
up and then just do about a quarter cup
of actually your fish sauce a little
more concentrated
none let us sit somewhere let it get
merry let it get happy so the purpose of
the lids is for it to basically steam
and cook on top if you don't have the
lid the bottom will burn but the top
won't cook so every now and then we're
gonna check it to see what's going on
and you don't want to open it up too
much because you're gonna let all that
cooking heat come out hmm it's about
ready oh oh wow so what are you looking
for we're looking for it to be crisp on
the bottom and cooked all the way
through on the top yeah so usually over
time because of the cast iron it'll the
pan over time will get hotter and hotter
so it'll be faster as you if you mess up
when you try these things out and it
doesn't seem right doesn't taste right
you know that's okay first time for
everything
and my suggestion is like when you do
eat or create things like if you see
this and you want to create at home go
out to a restaurant and eat it first
because you're not gonna know what's
supposed to taste like until you have a
good one
so how do we eat the Budden cup money
cook money so you put a little bit of
the grease that you made earlier top it
off with it so pretty
oh my god you look like the angel you
look like the model and then usually you
eat it with some fresh veggies how do
you eat it with the veggies you use it
as a wrap you could use it as a wrap or
I just throw everything together and I
just start eating I'm gonna grab some
i'ma get this little baby ass [ __ ] here
cuz that's pretty and then we're gonna
put this here yeah like so yep I'm gonna
take some of these fresh herbs blue from
our garden she just has to put that in
there ah put that on there and put a
little bit of the cab routes on there
bless ya oh and they're gonna eat it yes
eat it
oh good y'all usually my mom would make
like a bag maybe a bag and a half of the
batter for our entire family which is
six of us David came over I was like oh
let's make a bag and a half that's like
four six people and our family should be
fine man they ate it all before I even
sat down call me fat on my own show
not you everybody else that was there we
haven't you know season your cast iron
gets rusted like this Lin um sorry I'm
busy in B she and 2p she okay do not
touch it later okay I want you to burn
yourself I got what I had toss it in
frame oh wow
[ __ ] frame god damn that was terrible
tossing it frame [ __ ] it we're good
we're good we're gonna move on top six
are cool it's like the Asian people Fork
as I need to tell you we move past those
times when people of the lighter fair
skin color used to make fun of us
because we would use two sticks to cook
things and now look at you taking our
[ __ ] and acting like we didn't know
about it you're [ __ ]